This is a download from BBC Learning English. To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
The Olympic Games happened every four years and the most recent games were held in Tokyo this summer.
Did you watch them Sam?
Yes, I saw British swimmer Adam PC, winner gold medal and my personal favourite was 13-year-old
sky brown, competing in an exciting sport which was added to the Olympics this year.
skateboarding.
Olympic athletes inspire people around the world to take on new challenges,
eat healthily and get fit. So it seems strange that some of the companies that sponsor or pay for
the Olympic Games also sell food and drink which is linked to obesity, heart disease and diabetes.
tobacco advertising was banned from international sport in 2005 because of the harmful effects of
smoking. But other companies selling less than healthy products still sponsor the exhausting events.
These could be sugary drinks companies or others who sell fast food, hot food like hamburgers
that is quick to cook and serve which is often unhealthy.
In this programme we'll be asking whether it's right for companies selling unhealthy products
disponsors forting events.
Phoebe is A because they wanted to call french fries McFrys.
Okay Sam we'll find out the answer later in the programme.
Someone who is worried about the relationship between fast food and sport is Dr Sandra Dimaio.
He worked for the World Health Organization specialising in obesity before starting his own
public health agency in Australia.
Here is Dr Dimaio speaking with BBC World Service programme The Food Chain
about the problem with unhealthy brands and food products.
By having their brand alongside a young person's favourite sporting hero on the
chest of their national team it does two things. First of all it creates brand attachment so if you're
a young child and you build the connection in your mind that basically fast food equals success.
At the same time it also gives a health halo to that brand.
Then you start to think in your mind even subconsciously that it can't be that bad.
You've probably heard of brand loyalty where people have a favourite brand they always buy
but Dr Dimaio is concerned about brand attachment.
Brand attachment is the emotional connection between humans and brands.
It goes deeper than loyalty so that people mentally connect a particular company with feelings of
winning, being healthy and success.
The problem comes when these feelings attach to companies that aren't healthy at all.
Dr Dimaio says this creates a health halo.
The belief that something is good like an angel's halo even though there is little evidence to support this.
On the other hand fast food and fizzy drink companies invest large amounts of money in sport.
Over 4.5 billion dollars since the 2016 Rio Olympics.
Much of it supporting athletes around the world.
Yes with travel, training and equipment the cost of being an Olympic athlete can be huge.
And depending on your country and your sport there may be little financial help.
Many athletes are desperate for any sponsorship they can get.
Does that make it right to promote unhealthy eating in return?
Not according to Dr Dimaio who thinks people should worry about the nutritional value of fast food.
As he explained to BBC World Services the food chain.
When we think about foods and beverages of public health concern we tend to start by
talking about highly processed foods, particularly ultra processed foods.
These are foods that have been really broken down to their kind of basic elements and then
built up their more products really than foods.
You know they're made in a laboratory not a kitchen.
Dr Dimaio mentions unhealthy foods and beverages, another word for drinks.
He's concerned about the public health risk of ultra processed food.
Foods containing extra ingredients like chemicals,
colourings and sweetness that you wouldn't add when cooking homemade food.
A potato for example is natural, minimally processed,
make a potato when it becomes processed, make french fries and it's ultra processed.
And speaking of french fries Neil what was the answer to your question?
Yes I asked Sam the reason behind the decision McDonald's made not to sponsor the 2024 Paris Olympics.
And I said it was A because they wanted to call french fries McFrys.
Which was the wrong answer I'm afraid.
In fact McDonald's wanted to be the only company allowed to advertise cheese so it could boost
cheeseburger sales. This didn't go down well with officials in France, a country with over a
thousand different types of cheese. Okay let's recap the vocabulary from this programme starting with
fast food, hot food that is quick to cook but maybe unhealthy.
Companies that sponsor sports events pay for them to happen.
Brand attachment is a psychological connection between someone and a brand.
A health halo is the perception that something is healthy for you even if it's not.
Ultra processed foods are foods containing added artificial ingredients like colourings and preservatives.
And beverage is another word for a drink.
That's all from us but if you'd like to find out more about the business, science and culture of food
why not download the food chain podcast it's updated weekly and available now.
Join us again soon for more topical discussion and vocabulary here at 6 Minute English.
Bye for now. Bye!